on this aisle meet the forgotten villain
kids Harry
son of Captain Hook in son of Gaston and
Ursula daughter uma Friday July 21st
what's my name what's my name
you know I've dreamed of this I'm so
flattered that you dream of me they're
out for revenge
dad I could hook it because not all
villain kids want a shot at being good
if I went ringing the one came on
premieres Friday July 21st at 8:00 on
Disney Channel and now a sneak peek
behind the scenes of descendants - this
right here is a full-blown robot sword
fight we've just started filming
if contain too much fun it's going down
not only dance and choreo and singing we
learned has spent weeks and weeks and
weeks of rehearsal so much worse and
sweat and tears and messing up and you
got this you got this you got this I
trip every time I do that move - it's
beautiful
you wouldn't want it any other way
that's the best part the second we call
action the adrenaline just kind of goes
up the roof and everything is just so
amplified and so excited and the
Energy's almost electric because we
slept so long and I waited for this
moment for so long to be here is really
exciting there's so much happening in
the sequence like sword fights and cool
choreography I can now wait
for more check out descendants - it's
going down behind this new special
Friday July 7th at 7:30 on genichi at
all
is it on for this thing on hey I guess
hope you guys are gage we are now on the
set of the things to remember pretty
cool
what Monday what's my name what's my
name is definitely one of my favorite
songs because you know at home with
entrance it shows people who always
what's my name
unfilled China she is the Bob they'd be
rehearsing we'd all just like stop the
fantastic it's my name
[Music]
my name was my what's it say my bus to
coming to get me
you